your mind
it is the center of your life it is
everything you hear everything you see
everything you feel
it is everything you are
how would you know if someone stole your
mind
hey there and it's time for another 13
o'clock movie retrospective that's right
we're gonna retrospect we're gonna look
back on and it's Total Recall yes the
1990 version not the remake which sucked
yeah there's only one Total Recall
original we did see the remake but I
don't even remember all that much about
it yeah that's bad when it doesn't make
any impression yeah I could generic this
one here that has a lot of cat character
and this one I remember it's funny
because I haven't seen it for a really
long time and then we watched it like a
couple days ago because Tom got it on
blu-ray and I didn't like it as much as
I did originally yeah but it's still
like a really good mood like it still
holds up pretty good like some of the
effects still kind of look a little bit
dodgy yeah I remember it looked kind of
futuristic when it first came out but
you look at it now and it came out in
1990 yeah and you look at it and it
looks like 1994 yeah because I'm
watching it going everybody looks like
extras on Saved by the Bell
yeah I remember the clothes being
futuristic for the time and then you
look at it you like know that's what
they were wearing in 93 yeah because
there was still like some lingering
eighties influence because everyone's
hair was big and there was like some
kind of aerobics and [ __ ] going on it
almost makes you wonder if the clothes
were product placement for a new
clothing line if it's coming out in JC
Penney's or something it might have been
because there was a lot of product
placement in that yeah a lot and you
know but the interesting thing about
Total Recall is that it's actually kind
of surprising that it even got made yeah
I was in development hell yeah because
like evidently this [ __ ] script had
been making the rounds of Hollywood for
like years and it went through like 40
different drafts yeah right and like
Dino De Laurentiis owned the property
for a long time and it went around it
different now originally David
Cronenberg was supposed to direct it
which I would pay good money to see [ __ ]
he should still do that David Cronenberg
so um but so then that didn't it like he
wrote 12 different drafts and worked on
it for like a year and then I didn't
work out you know there was just all
this [ __ ] about it
and the movie never would have happen if
it wasn't for Arnie yeah because at this
point there had been so many and I don't
really think any stir every studio just
like [ __ ] it Dino De Laurentiis lost
interest yeah he's just like we can't
get a good script going for this and
it's just not worth it and evidently
Arnold Schwarzenegger really really
wanted to be in this movie
yeah now he actually I think he
auditioned for it when Dino De
Laurentiis still owned the property and
was turned down right because see in the
original story I mean I'm sure most of
you know but it's based on a philip k
dick story called we can remember it for
you wholesale which was published in
1966 and in the original story the main
character who his last name was Quayle
not Quaid like in the movie was actually
not like a big burly construction worker
he was more of like a nebbishy everyman
kind of character he was an accountant
and stuff like that yeah he was kind of
a more of a nerdy character so I think
that was originally the direction they
were going in and they didn't really
want Arnold Schwarzenegger being in it
because they didn't see him as right for
the role it should also be noted that
Arnold Schwarzenegger had also wanted to
be in Robocop but was also turned out
for that that have been awesome I know
it actually would have been pretty but I
can't imagine it with anybody other than
Peter Weller yeah Peter Weller so um I
could imagine Arnold in that role yeah
good but no it would be two Terminator
II yeah I think it's just it's basically
the same role as that yeah but Marvel
was becoming a parody of himself yeah so
evidence so Arnold wanted to do Total
Recall so bad that he talked this
production company into buying the
rights off the you know De Laurentiis
and he said if you buy the rights off
this that I'll star in it and actually
Arnold got a great deal of creative
control over the movie like he got to
assign the director he got to pick the
other actors he got to approve the
script all this [ __ ] right and he got
15% like not only did he get several
million dollars salary but he also got
like 15% of the box office or something
like that
yes it was a harmless plant project yeah
it really was like his movie yeah so
that's kind of how it eventually ended
up getting made and he actually did
choose Paul Verhoeven to direct it
who also directed Robocop and Paul bear
Ravana turned him down for being a robot
so but for some reason he really wanted
to work it well yeah so so he picked him
too Arnie wasn't personal about he
didn't take it personally yeah he was
all bad business yeah okay so now as I
said the original story that this was
based on and then after the movie came
out there was also a novelization of it
which was actually written by Piers
Anthony who is like a pretty famous
fantasy writer now both the original
story and the novelization are a lot
less ambiguous than the 1990 film was
yeah for years there's always been this
controversy was Total Recall
a hallucination was it a dream or did he
actually do this stuff right that's you
know when you see the movie you
understand and most of you privacy in
the movie yeah because in the original
story which didn't have the whole spy
angle and all that other kind of stuff
you know it did have the kind of
hallucination of implanted memories kind
of deal but it was a different
quote-unquote hallucination now but in
the original philip k dick story it was
made clear that it was not a
hallucination that all this stuff that
he remembered this crazy stuff about
aliens and stuff like that actually did
happen and I believe that the
novelization that was based on the 1990
movie also made it clear that it really
happened however the movie and I don't
care if you want to argue with me in
this era about this secret in the
comments but the movie I think was a
dream it was it was implanted memory it
didn't he didn't really go to Mars he
didn't really do any of that [ __ ] they
left a lot of hints that kind of left it
ambiguous but because those hints are
there it's a hallucination yes ma'am I
mean I think it was it was nicely done
because I think Paul beare joven and I
think if you watch the UM because we
have the blu-ray I haven't watched it
yet but um the director commentary but
I've seen that other people that have
watched it said that Paul Verhoeven's
says in there that oh I wanted to leave
it so it could go either way but a lot
of the stuff he says leans to it being a
dragon right hallucination and honestly
I think that that interpretation makes a
lot more yeah it makes a lot more sense
because if all that [ __ ] really happened
then there's a lot of plot holes that
need to be right is all I'm saying
so you know most most of you have
probably seen it right in Till's with a
construction worker kind of an everyman
working-class kind of guy and he's
evidently not happy with his life and
all this other stuff no he has a nice
job nice apartment he's married to
Sharon Stone you know whatever um yeah
the scene with Sharon said oh say what
she couldn't act no she really yeah I I
think it was really kind of like was she
even and I mean I know she got real big
in Basic Instinct and she was in like a
few other movies but I think she could
act later but she wasn't acting too well
in this movie and Arnold's acting
depends on who he's playing against yeah
and you know like in predator he was
awesome yeah that was his best work but
when he was acting against Sharon Stone
when they were doing that scene together
it was almost kind of high school level
acting it wasn't it wasn't believable
well they put it on Sharon really well
there wasn't a lot of chemistry but you
know either maybe they even like each
other maybe not I mean even though I
guess Arnold was um okay here's the
thing though if the whole thing that
happened to him about going to Mars and
everything like that and Sharon Stone
being a secret agent who was you know a
plant there to like keep an eye on him
and [ __ ] like that then maybe him and
her not really getting along maybe that
would have explained why in his
hallucination he wanted to kill her and
he was like dreaming about this
otherwise remember that I remember the
scene feeling very wooden an artificial
did yeah and I don't know like I said
yet it can't be it was supposed to be
that way yeah it can make sense in the
context of this story but it's hard to
tell whether it was deliberate or not
because it doesn't look deliberate it
just looks like badass yeah just that
one scene feels unnatural to me the rest
of the movie you know almost doing a
pretty good job yeah it with the rest of
it works pretty bright but like I said
it might have just been the interaction
between him and Sharon Stone it's felt
very awkward and stagey and not really
all that natural yeah in fact looking
back at the movie when you go and see it
now all of it pretty much looks stage II
all the action or blocking it looks very
artificial that was very common so that
common type
it was very much a mall movie it was
like the impression of like you're
seeing something happening in a ball
yes movie was presence by a ball very it
was very what's a good way to put it
very corporate feel to the to the movie
that is a good way yeah yeah and it's
it's interesting because you think and
and actually it having that feel would
actually make more sense if the [ __ ]
that happened to him really happened
because it was like run by a big deal
like an evil corporation and all the
same stuff but honestly it it might
important like I like the movie but it
might have worked better if it was done
more surrealist yeah do you know what
I'm saying
predator one was very organic it was
much like a war movie okay yeah
something happening in Vietnam that's
what it felt like right real in a way
you know felt like it was a real
occurrence Total Recall feels kinda like
a corporate infomercial yeah it's like
an informant it has an infomercial
quality to the way this yeah where the
whole movie it feels and the way it was
shot and I don't think it was intended
yeah it's just like a like it was built
to a formula like what was what was that
other one was that Sylvester Stallone
when we were watching the other day
demolition man yeah it has a similar
kind of so it's very similar kind of
vibe to it yeah but those came out about
the same time later later okay
demolition man was like one of the last
of these action movie big blockbuster
type action movies that formulas seem to
be getting pretty tired
around the time demolition man came out
yeah it really couldn't get away with
that anymore but well I don't know well
the thing about I mean I think the best
thing about Total Recall is the
ambiguity yeah I mean I like that they
give you like all these little clues and
you don't really know know okay
the only thing that I think suggests
that the [ __ ] really happened and some
people pointed this out know it really
happened because one he dreamed about
Molina before ostensibly got the memory
implant
yeah but until a recall or the recall
not told no what's it called the company
the company was just called Rico yeah
the company is called recall the recall
company had photos of all the secret
Martian artifacts yeah in the background
you see that plan yeah that's another
thing like if like he goes there and
they specifically say okay here's the
Mars package and here and we have a new
variation of it where you can go as a
different character we have a look at
ego trip yes cause if you go true yeah
so you can go as a spy right and like
everyone's gonna be killing you trying
to kill you and like you'll meet a
beautiful mysterious woman or an exotic
woman or where they asked him you know
are you gay you gave you straight okay
what kind of women do you like
Oh blah yeah and they show milena
appearing right so obviously I mean if
it was real how would they have a
picture of her how would and here the
thing too is that yeah he dreamed about
her before he supposedly got the memory
implant but here's the thing though and
I'm pretty sure I'd have to watch this
again but I'm pretty sure that when he
goes in there and they start to give him
you know the first because I guess they
do it in stages right they give him kind
of a thing that makes him go to sleep
before they put the implant in herself
so when he's starting to go to sleep
that's when they're showing him you know
pick out the woman you want now when the
woman first comes up on the screen and
he says oh I want a brunette and she's
like sleazy and a mirror which I thought
was very funny and but it looks like a
generic woman and then it resolves
itself into her so I feel like from that
point forward we're seeing everything
from Arnie's perspectives were seeing
everything from his fantasy yeah some of
it could have been put in put retro
actively into his memory to about his
friends at work watching him and
watching all I know what's weird is that
I never saw anyone else point that out
but I was like you know if a company is
capable of implanting memories yeah they
can pull up and plant false memories
they can implant false memories of you
that happened before you even worry
about it
before you went there yeah they give you
a new history right so they could have
implanted a memory of you remembering
something that happened before you went
to
right right like you know because some
people have said oh well his friend at
work that warned him against going to
recall like gave him like a weird dirty
look or something like that
but it was like well one that doesn't
necessarily mean that no he could have
remembered that that could have been
implanted memory yeah that could have
either been in a Planet memory or that
could have just been like a
misinterpretation like that guy that
look could have meant pretty much
anything right it could have just met oh
well I think he's gonna go anyway
dumbass I told him not to get his little
hole about anything but the whole thing
you could pretty much resolve the whole
thing it was written the movie was
written to be interpreted kind of either
way either way be kind of ambiguous but
really a realist and say no that was a
hallucination and honestly gonna be a
realist you have to say so yeah like but
that's kind of the cool thing about it
and that's kind of a difficult thing to
do is write something where - you know
opposite interpretations are possible
but like I said I mean a strict reading
of the movie I really don't think that
any of that [ __ ] could have happened in
real life because like I said there's
not only the whole thing with Molina
being in the computer at recall there
was also all the pictures that they
showed in the background oh and one of
the text says Oh blue skies on Mars
that's a new one or something like that
and that's exactly what happens at the
end of the movie right
you know when the movie ends and he sees
a blue sky on Mars because he opens up
there he starts the Martian engine or
whatever that gives Mars an atmosphere
and the sky turns blue and you know and
also there are pictures in the
background a tree call when he's getting
the implant that show the quote unquote
secret Martian artifact supposedly
nobody on earth knows about right
because they were just saying oh well
they found new Martian artifacts that we
added that to the package yeah in his
hallucination when the guy from recall
appears to talk him out of his ego trip
remember that guy foretells he predicts
everything that everything that's going
to happen for the rest of the movie yeah
all that stuff does happen right he's
tripping it's an ego trip yeah and some
people have said oh well that when the
doctor shows up and tries to get him to
take the pill to talk him out of it oh
the the thing of sweat goes down is
if he wasn't real then why would that
sweaty there I said yeah but you're
seeing everything from Arnold's
perspective right yeah and Arnold is not
seeing things as they really are no he
is either and even with the
hallucination interpretation there are
actually two possibilities there is the
possibility that the memory implant or
the ego trip is working exactly as
planned and that all these things like
the doctor coming there were
pre-programmed to make it seem more
realistic yeah now there's the theory
tell me the theory at the end with the
flashlight oh well I'm gonna get to that
how's that okay so that's one
possibility now the other possibility is
that what the doctor says really
happened that they implanted the memory
and then Arnold's own fantasies or his
schizoid embolism quote-unquote made the
program go awry right so if they don't
get him back out then he's going to have
to be lobotomize just like the other guy
that his buddy at work told him about
right and when he and when Arnold first
goes to recall and asked about the
lobotomize guy they don't deny that that
happened yeah just say I'm saying she's
history yeah they so it was a long time
ago and every now and that happens where
we can't pull people out of the fantasy
and you have to end up lobotomizing them
or they you know they'll never be normal
or whatever so now if this
interpretation of the hallucination is
correct if indeed Arnold's brain did
start to build upon this memory implant
and made everything go crazy like go in
a way that it wasn't supposed to go and
if that doctor came and that was correct
that he was saying you know you have to
let us get you out of here or you're
never going to be able to get out of
this fantasy if that was what was really
happening but at the very end of this
story you know where he says oh what if
this is all a dream and Bellini says
well then kiss me quick before you wake
up then the screen right before the
credits the screen goes white not black
now in movie technical terms fading to
white usually means
dream or flashback right I guess so some
people have said because they
specifically faded it to white and not
black then that means that our
lobotomize right Wow and I mean I think
that maybe okay there are two reasons I
think that that's probably why one
because why would they brought up the
other guy that got lobotomized at the
beginning of the movie if that wasn't
what they were hinting was gonna happen
to Arnold later I mean otherwise there
wouldn't be any reason to bring that up
or even write it into the story and to
their Hoban was very very big fan of
putting downer endings in his movies but
not faux-fur CLE right you know what I
mean he'd like to sneak down her endings
so I kind of feel like maybe he did that
like just as a little bit of a like you
know it seems like a happy ending
because he Carl and he saved the planet
and stuff like that but because the
whole thing was a hallucination
and because the fantasy had gone on so
much that Arnold would never be able to
get back out of the fantasy that they
just lobotomized him and chucked him in
the next scrap heap that's probably what
happened that's kind of what I feel like
my interpretation isn't sorry if I
ruined the movie for anybody it doesn't
have to be that I'm just saying look at
it either way yeah you can look at it
either way I mean it could be that at
the end when the screen went white
that just means oh he woke up from his
ego trip which went entirely was planned
he was in recall right so it was so
alive he just went back to his regular
life with these memories of having saved
Mars and stuff like that but I tend to
think that everything went wrong the
whole the whole tale is too good to be
true
yeah mortal man couldn't do all that it
was the ego trip he was true and see
some people have said too that it's like
oh well if it didn't really happen
then why were there's why were there all
these other scenes with other characters
where Arnold wasn't present because he
wouldn't know about any of that stuff
going on I was like one that could have
been just for ease of plot like you know
watching the movie so you can enjoy the
trip better yeah but yeah also I'm like
if they implanted memories and you've
had dreams before where there were other
people like talking about characters and
you knew you were there were characters
they weren't there necessarily but you
you know so I
think that really holds up as an
argument because I'm like well it was
just playing into the hole I mean if you
were a spy or if you were hallucinating
that you were a spy then there would be
all these scenes of the bad guys talking
about you and how they were gonna get
you and stuff like that and they totally
could have put that into the program
yeah to make it seem like a more
realistic experience yeah I mean I would
think it's still a good movie it is
showing its age it is a big it did it
did show its age more than I because
it's like I said it had been a long time
since technology was pretty hokey yeah
remember the intercoms with the video
strains on it that looked like 1990 yeah
the cars that were in it were not
believable they basically looked like
the era's they were they were golf carts
yeah they're gone yeah the Fiero was I
think I saw Fiero and I think I saw a
Nissan 290 or 280 Z yes from the
nightmare but the ones that they were
riding in like the Johnny cab and
everything looks a little golf cart
that's probably exactly that one they
didn't look anything as didn't look
anywhere near as good as demolition man
that came out yeah it's weird because
demolition man even though I like Total
Recall a lot more than demolition man
they actually got a lot more accurate in
demolition man as far as far as the
technology go I think demolition man is
92 but and you know we were talking
about this when we were talking about
this movie before doing the show I was
like now I think this is why one this is
why I would never do a sci-fi movie like
if I was ever in a position to make a
movie with millions of dollars I would
not choose to do sci-fi because it's too
difficult to not have it look like [ __ ]
yeah 10 years from now 20 years from now
it's a very dangerous genre in that
sense because anything you predict about
the future and even though Total Recall
they didn't I know I don't remember if
they came out and said in the movies
universe what year was know I never knew
although if you look it up it's supposed
to be 2084 okay yeah they never
but I don't think they ever mentioned it
in the movie but anything you do it's
like people are gonna see that movie in
10 years 20 years ago yeah really
right yeah we're all gonna be wearing
big [ __ ] calculators on our wrists
because you never know when you might
need to add some [ __ ] yeah and all that
kind of [ __ ] and that's why we were
saying that's why I think movies like
2001 or Star Wars or something like that
works so well still yeah because they
didn't really they didn't really take it
too well one they kept it kind of
mythical yeah and also they the universe
was so large that they kind of had a
variety of different you know the
different civilizations were of
different technological levels of
progress they also never really focused
in on the and make a big deal out of the
technology yes I just right they just
tell a normal story there just happens
to be taking yeah and I think that's
kind of the problem too with a lot of
quote-unquote hard sci-fi is I think if
you focus too much on the technology
aspect then your story's gonna date very
quickly right because you know that
technology is not gonna look so awesome
like five ten years from now and I can't
really think of many sci-fi movies that
don't look dated yeah even as even 5-10
years later
yeah so I just think it's a really
dangerous thing to do and I think that
Total Recall kind of fell into that trap
a little bit because you know memory
implant we don't have those yet and
stuff so they could have just stuck with
that don't try not to show computers try
not to show you know don't make
everybody look like they have
quote-unquote futuristic clothes on and
stuff like that because that's always
that's yeah it's just never gonna work
out to your advantage ons used in Total
Recall were really dated for the time
you know clarity of hi-tech pistol
Calico m9 hundreds you know very much
guns of the eighties yeah
so that's what I mean it's kind of like
so it's not necessarily the movies fault
because it's kind of you know a risk
that you take when you make a sci-fi
movie but it did kind of kind of date
some and it does kind of interfere with
your enjoyment of the movie a little bit
although I have to say
the special effects like some of the
special effects and it still look pretty
good like a lot of the practical effects
okay I'm like disguised as other people
and kind of [ __ ] I've got the blu-ray
pretty cheap I think I got it on eBay
for under five dollars yeah including
shipping yeah but I must say that the
the blu-ray really just was a good DVD
copy it didn't look like it had been
remastered or anything yeah I'm not sure
if it had it didn't look quite as good
as like some of the other blue yea
blu-rays that we had like we got the
thing and stuff like that didn't those
look beautiful they look like they've
just been totally redone just watch
Videodrome last night yeah yeah it looks
good yeah we're gonna have to do a
review of that too because I love David
currently and I love video drum and yeah
we just got that and yeah Videodrome
looks great yeah well that well that's a
generator one yeah got that I'm blu-ray
video drum that was a criterion
collections so they take a lot of time
to do even and the packaging is super
cool I say from a bonus I'm a graphic
designer standpoint yeah it looks like a
Betamax it looks like a Betamax like
there's a handwritten it's very very
cool but yeah so I would definitely
recommend getting that Total Recall
I you know I recommend getting it if you
like but if you haven't seen it for a
long time like I said it it looked a lot
more dated than I remembered yeah it
looks like a 90's mall yeah because I
hadn't seen it in many many years oh and
another thing I forgot to mention was
that the movie Minority Report which was
of course also based on a different
philip k dick story was initially
intended to be a sequel to Total Recall
Wow and it was gonna have Doug Quaid the
Canada main character he was gonna be in
it and the precogs were going to be the
the mutants the meters from Mars which
was actually David Cronenberg's idea
cool that was one of the only ideas from
one of David Cronenberg's scripts that
stayed in the final movie was the
mutated people on Mars but yeah so later
on you know Minority Report is rewritten
to be a standalone movie but initially
it was supposed to be the Total Recall
sequel yeah so Total Recall it's worth -
it's worth it to read I still enjoyed it
but it's it's it's dated yeah you can
just you can tell like I said the best
thing about it is the ambiguity and try
to pick up all the little clues of
whether it's a dream and whether it's
not
it's kind of a head [ __ ] that way and I
kind of like [ __ ] like that I said it's
it's almost kind of like a working man's
version of like Mulholland Drive or like
a David Lynch movie or it's like you
know all the dream [ __ ] is like a little
symbolic and everything like that so
it's kind of like that Mulholland Drive
that's never be I definitely wanted to
ask my favorite David Lynch memory but
yeah so that'll do it for this latest
movie retrospective hope you have
enjoyed it and we will have more up soon
like I said we want to do video German
might do the first Terminator a couple
of other ones yeah we got it we've got a
lot of good ones that we got just
recently they live we got to do one -
Excalibur yeah so we've got a bunch of
new movies in the list and if you have
any recommendations we will try to get
around to it because we have a huge list
of like honor memory so it gets here but
other than that hope you enjoyed this
one and we will see you next time see
you guys